with season five you guys found your
home in Philadelphia how would you say
Philly and the vibe of that place really
convinced once the season wait let me
just say this mugging you look gorgeous
like ready what a lovely vision you are
and I will say Philly was credible I'd
never be was interesting because it's a
different beast from our seasons before
someone called I want one because this
is a 5/5 confident that you shouldn't do
that because we should only use name one
responsibly it's just it was a chopper
it was a tough sell because they thought
they really feel like they know
themselves and so to be able to
encourage them to open up and let us in
was hot think if the pant was rate up
it's very obvious to us how you change
lives of so many people you work with a
variety of people love the first episode
with Noah the gay pastor it was just
such an emotional episode I have
struggled with my identity as a gay
person I feel like I can't be the kind
of leader in the church that it could be
we see how you change their lives but
how do we impact your lives
our heroes aren't just the ones going
through change we are as well we go
through a lot of emotions as well and
often you guys don't see that because
you know the cameras don't follow us
home when we go home and cry ourselves
to sleep but yeah it sometimes can be
very hard but I love it because it helps
us grow tan how does it feel knowing
that you're able to bring so much
confidence to so many people
I guess all I'm saying is I wanted to
look sexy and I don't know if I can say
that to a pastor but I want you to okay
okay
main perk of the job is now that you
have such an impact on somebody's life
you take somebody who wouldn't even look
at themselves in the mirror let alone
looking at themselves in a negative way
in the mirror and then know that by the
time you leave they can hold a head up
high and weave all sorts of words in our
lives with low self-esteem and whose
beautiful confidence and thankfully
aspire in a position now where we are we
feel what we could offer the world don't
don't get wrong we don't feel confident
every day I think that is impossible
what we know our strengths we know what
we offer our community we know our we
offer our heroes and to be able to pass
that
some people feels really special a lot
of people have embraced the PJs track
pants they're posting about on placing
media that's why I was so shocked by
what you've got on gym shorts underneath
so what advice would you have to elevate
our at-home looks right now but I would
say is is very simply this if you look
in the mirror and see a version of
yourself that you don't like that you
don't recognize that is something that
is wrong we can control very little
right now there's so much going on in
the world that we have zero control over
and so to just have this one thing we
get up out of bed in the morning you
look at yourself in the mirror you get
to this side hugging from yourself and
that they've been really powerful